[Musique]
Jacqueline de romignier est-ce que ça
vous dit quelque chose non pas du tout
mais oui très bien je l'ai eu comme prof
bonjour madame bonjour vous savez où
vous êtes là dans chartre je me dirige
vers la cathédrale ouais et là vous êtes
place Jacqueline de romign est-ce que ça
vous dit quelque chose non non non une
passion extraordinaire pour la langue
grec et un souci un souci de la
perfection c'est mon lieu de d'arrêt
dans la la promenade dans la visite de
la ville j'habite place Jacqueline de
[Musique]
ROMILLE bonjour à toutes et tous et
bienvenue à chartre en direction de la
place Jacqueline de romill cette belle
ville d'heur etloire voit naître
l'illustre académicienne en
1913 après avoir fait de brillantes
études à Paris avoir enseigné en lycée
elle devient professeur de langue et de
littérature grecque à l'Université de
Lille et à la
Sorbonne en 1973 Jacqueline de romign
est nommée première femme professeur au
Collège de France la démocratie les
tragiqu la loi c'est son dada elle a
consacré une vie entière à la
littérature grec- ancienne en 1975
elle est la première femme membre de
l'Académie des inscriptions et des
belles lettres qu'elle présidera
d'ailleurs en 198
puis en 1988 elle devient la deè femme
élue à l'Académie française au fauteuil
d'André
Roussin en 1995 elle reçoit la
nationalité grecque elle décédera en
2010 laissant à sa ville de naissance
l'honneur et la fierté de lui consacrer
cette si jolie place Jacqueline de
[Musique]
romidi
nous allons désormais à la rencontre de
Claire Barbier guide conférencière
passionné de patrimoine d'histoire qui a
d'ailleurs habité non loin de cette
place Jacqueline de romini et qui va
nous expliquer en quoi cet endroit
occupe une place importante dans la vie
des charrains et des
ches bonjour Claire bonjour Céline
Jacqueline de romini elle vous inspire
quoi elle a réussi malgré tout un tas de
choses négatives qui sont arrivées dans
sa vie puisque notamment la deuxème
guerre mondiale elle russi à faire son
doctorat entre 40 et 47 donc voilà c'est
une femme qui avait du courage et qui
allait jusqu'au bout de ses idées et
quel regard vous poser sur les femmes
comme Jacqueline de Romy à l'époque
philosophe jusqu'à aujourd'hui elles
avaient beaucoup de courage ces
femmes-là parce qu'elles étaient dans un
un univers où les hommes avaient
beaucoup plus de place et de pouvoir sur
les femmes qu'aujourd'hui et ce serait
bien que ces femmes-là parce qu'il y en
a d'autres mine de rien et bien elles
sortent de des placards et qu'on les
redécouvre et qu'ell soit aussi
inspirante pour d'autres femmes et
d'autres générations clair pour vous ce
quartier il a un sens très particulier
puisque je crois que vous avez habité
ici alors oui effectivement parce que on
est vraiment sur cette plage Jacqueline
de romili le passage un des points clés
de la ville entre les habitants de la
ville haute et de la ville basse ceux de
la ville basse qui vont aller faire du
shopping en ville haute aller au marché
par exemple aller au cinéma donc ils ont
besoin de passer par cette place là et
les gens la ville haute qui veulent
aller se promener au bord de l'heure et
bien ils vont passer aussi par cette
place Jacqueline de romili Claire merci
beaucoup chartre résolument une histoire
de Dame des histoires d'amour mais c'est
aussi ça femme de marue et n'oubliez pas
des fleurs des cœurs des couleurs du
bonheur même pas
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
peur